Speaker 2: Okay.
One of the last things from CPAC.
Speaker 1: That we're going to talk about
and many so many of you emailed me about,
this is the Michael Knowles Anti-transgender
moment.
Now, before I play this clip of Michael Knowles,
and remember, this is one of the Daily Wire
guys, and I've been on his program a couple
of times and I stopped doing it because I
really got nothing out of it.
And just, you know, his audience doesn't like
me and my audience already knows me.
And there was just no real benefit to going
and arguing with him about nonsense.
Speaker 2: So for a couple of years now.
Speaker 1: The anti-trans and homophobic lines
get the best reactions.
At CPAC.
The CPAC crowds have been increasingly dead
other than when they do anti-trans or homophobic
stuff.
We saw it from Trump last year.
We saw it from Ted Cruz at some recent CPAC
where he said, My pronouns are kiss my ass
and, you know, the anti-trans anti homophobia,
the anti-gay stuff still does really well.
And Matt Walsh, who's another one of these
Daily Wire guys, has really found a lucrative
niche in doing the anti-trans stuff.
So clearly, Michael Knowles is trying to copy
it.
He's saying, Hey, whoa, the gravy train with
the anti trans stuff is working really well
for Matt Walsh.
Let me jump in on it.
So he's talked about the need to eliminate
transgenderism.
So this is an example of the anti-trans stuff
from CPAC.
Take a look.
Speaker 6: There can be no middle way in dealing
with transgenderism.
It is all or nothing.
If transgenderism is true, if men really can
become women, then it's true for everybody
of all ages.
If transgender is an.
Is false as it is.
If men really can't become women, as they
cannot, then it's false for everybody to.
Speaker 2: Now, I want let me.
Speaker 1: Address this for a moment.
Speaker 2: They insist on this.
Speaker 1: Thing where they want to know the
truth about whether a man can be a woman or
whether a woman can be a man.
And they want to argue about it's all.
Speaker 2: It's just truth and biology.
Neil deGrasse.
Speaker 1: Tyson, in an interview with Ben
SHAPIRO few weeks ago, made a really good
point, which is, listen.
Speaker 2: The if you want to talk about the
unassailable facts, undeniable, no one can
deny this.
The undeniable fact is that people express
gender.
Speaker 1: On a spectrum.
Speaker 2: You can't deny that.
It is an absolutely incontrovertible truth
that there is a spectrum of gender expression
for all birth biological sex that exist.
People express gender on a spectrum.
You've got more and less feminine men.
Speaker 1: And on and on.
Speaker 2: So as Neil deGrasse Tyson eloquently
said, there are aspects.
Speaker 1: Of this which are questions for
a biology class.
There are aspects of this which are questions
for a sociology class.
There are aspects of this that are questions
for.
Speaker 2: Sports leagues to determine rules,
no doubt.
And we've got to figure out where that is.
But if you want to talk about facts, it is
a fact that people express.
Speaker 1: Gender on a spectrum.
And so when they.
Speaker 2: Talk about we just want the truth.
Can a man be a woman?
It's one of the worst faith, but also ignorant.
Speaker 1: Things you can say.
Speaker 2: Because all you need to do is look
at the world around you and you know that
it is true that gender.
Speaker 1: Is expressed on a spectrum.
They they want to make it a conversation about
something else.
Let's listen to the last few seconds.
Speaker 6: And if it's false, then we should
not indulge it, especially since that indulgence
requires taking away the rights and customs
of so many people.
If it is false, does it for the good of society,
and especially for the good of the poor people
who have fallen prey to this confusion.
Transgenderism must be eradicated from public
life entirely.
Speaker 1: Now, numerous headlines after this
speech said, Oh, he wants to get rid of transgender
people.
He just he wants to get rid of them.
That's absolutely horrible.
And Michael Knowles and other people associated
with him have come to his defense with a line
like, that's not true.
He didn't say do anything to the people.
He said, get rid of the ISM.
Speaker 2: Get eradicate.
Speaker 1: Transgender ism.
Speaker 2: Not kill the.
Speaker 1: Trans people.
Speaker 2: Now, I think we need only.
Speaker 1: One very simple hypothetical to
explore whether that is a good faith defense
of what Michael Moore said.
Speaker 2: Imagine, imagine that.
Speaker 1: Michael Knowles or whoever had
said.
Speaker 2: We need to eradicate Judaism.
Oh, my God.
Are you calling for genocide?
No, no, no, no.
I didn't say anything about eradicating Jews.
I meant eradicate Judaism completely.
Speaker 1: Do you think we would all accept
that?
Speaker 2: A go?
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
He's not saying anything about Jews.
He's just saying eradicate Judaism.
Speaker 1: Get rid of it completely.
Oh, yeah.
The Anti-Defamation League would be fine with
that defense.
This is a pathetic attempt to soften, but
also put others on the defensive.
And some went for it.
There are some news outlets that, after Knowles
complained, changed their headlines.
And we all know what he's talking about.
He is using.
Speaker 2: He is saying out loud in more.
Speaker 1: Explicit terms what a ton of these
right wingers are thinking.
And it's dangerous and it's disgusting and
it needs to be condemned.
And he can't be allowed to walk it back by
going, no, no, no, I didn't say anything about
trans people I met.
Just get rid of the ism.
What do you what exactly do you mean by that?
This is what they are getting the biggest
reactions to.
We started seeing it a year or two ago.
We've done interviews about it.
Speaker 2: The anti LGBT.
Speaker 1: And now specifically focused on
anti-trans stuff.
It is back.
They are going to write it to a pot of gold
if they are allowed to.
Matt Walsh already did Michael know Knowles
is trying for it.
I would like to see some Republicans.
This is a great opportunity for Mitt Romney.
This is a great opportunity for whoever wants
to come forward and say that I have to condemn.
Let's see if any of them do.